this is really exciting our show or our
talk today is small sticky and squishy
okay so some of you have already seen
that this comes to play outside but
before we start I want to say and there
are a number of people so you might
recognize all these spaces here these
are the people that help with a squishy
specific demos out in the hallway and
who made the bucket of cornstarch
outside there are also some people that
aren't here today in the engineering
school who helped contribute some
resources we've got support from Yale
Center for engineering innovation and
design and also a big THANK YOU and a
shout out to the National Science
Foundation who pays for our research and
help support these outreach activities
okay thank you out of the way let's
start talking about some science okay
and so I want to start off with a
question for all of you to think about
and that question is how is a drop of
water behave so what does it drop what
are do it drops what else is it doing
just shout it out don't raise your hand
you're alright okay so why they say drop
water you might think of a small drop of
water like a little shiny drop of dew on
a blade of grass or on a drop of dew on
the spiderweb and in that case drops of
water don't do much except to sort of
sit there and have a round shape right
but what if I make money drop bigger
plus it can you think of what a bigger
drop of water would look like shed to
shatter what it might be a rain drop
what about that what's that River it's
actually a link a link it's just a
really big drop of water is it doing the
same thing is a little the smaller drop
yes and go right
so yes it's just sort of sitting there
mostly but it's not a big round sphere
right it's really flat so there's a
difference between a big drop of water
and a little drop of water can someone
think of something up that drop of water
that's even bigger than a link oh [ __ ]
right so ocean being totally differently
from a lake or a drop of dude they're
all just water right except the ocean is
huge and the [ __ ] thing that happens
with the oceans you get all this crazy
waves and this crazy waste happen just
because to drop the water is bigger okay
so one of the things I want you to
remember just from today you remember
one thing remember that small and big
are different you probably already know
that small and bigger difference visit
of different sizes but small things made
out of the same stuff as big things can
became different okay and businesses and
engineers and chemists church structure
everything they think about about how
big it is
okay so here's a map of basically
everything right I have this is a scale
where in meters so I have the big
you can imagine actually it's actually a
small fraction of the universe the Milky
Way it's one with 21 zeros after it
eaters across right and on the other
side I've got the inside of a proton
which is one of the smallest things
inside of an atom right and that's one
divided by one with 15 zeros after it
okay so it's a cheese and somewhere in
between around 1 meter is my daughter on
one who's sitting right there and if you
just go through on when to this just
this tiny little bit difference from
here to here is the difference between
my daughter and be struck right and this
from your ear is pretty strong to all of
the Northeast so imagine how big this
stuff is this is really big stuff and
similarly on this side it's really
really tiny stuff and will give us
businesses and chemists and all that
stuff is trying to figure out how these
things go ok so now that we want to talk
so that was a little shtick about small
and big I want to focus on one
particular aspect of sloping right now I
don't want to talk about why this drop
water is all rounded up a little drop my
little drop downs up even though a link
is nice and flat because anyone guess
why our lovely cos flat looks like flat
for sure right through my falling down
for gravity something else is going on
over the little stuff okay I'm gonna
move on we can talk after so all right
so okay so if you have imagine that you
have like a crazy microscope that'd be
like that you can this is so good you
can see atoms and molecules if you zoom
in to water okay
if you zoomed water and look at the
surface of water if I sort of look like
something
okay all the little blue circles are
meant to look like water molecules what
world does actually look like Mickey
Mouse but that's harder to draw so I
just made them Spears okay so if you
look at these water these molecules are
inside of the drop of water how cute
there's no water and their gears to drop
the atoms or molecules on the surface
what's the difference between the
molecules on the surface from the ones
inside so molecules inside the condensed
phases like liquids and solids like to
make bonds with each other okay they
like to make bonds that's good in terms
of energy and the molecules that are
inside of the material the pockets are
represented as these little red lines so
this one on the inside has six neighbors
he can make bombs too so he's really
happy okay
or she's really happy the water molecule
on the surface he has four friends
instead of six okay so he's not okay so
these molecules on the surface aren't
this happened because they can make as
many thoughts okay so we're molecule so
what do they do they try to get off of
the surface okay so imagine that I did
and I had a sheet of water okay and I
have a picture on the top and the
picture on the bottom they have the same
number of water molecules okay the water
in the top has a lot more unhappy
molecules because there's a lot
that's the one that are slightly
different color than the one on the
bottom what's the difference we do with
the top of the bottom went to the lower
to the water she have to wait in the
back yeah what does it have to do this
way that way okay does that make sense
see there are less white toilets here
than there are there so the lower there
are more happy water molecules so it
turns out that there's this force come
surface tension that surfaces supply to
the rest of the liquid that pull the
liquid film in to try to make as few
molecules as possible on the surface
okay and right now we have a few demos
that we're going to show you dr. Larry
violet or dr. bubble as he likes to be
known is going to do a few demos here
with the overhead projector she first
showing off how surface than she works
like this okay so I've got a rig here
with a string tied between it we see
that gravity likes to pull the string
down but now we're going to dip it in a
solution and what we have here is a soap
bubble on both sides of the stream and
because of this surface tension force
it's pulling on the string from both
directions but because it's pulling on
both sides gravity still wants the
string to hang downward but I'm gonna
pop the soap bubble on the bottom and I
want you to watch carefully what happens
to the string pulled upward and that's
the force of surface tension in action
and then if I pop them a little on top
it drops back down so you can see
surface tension in action it's a pretty
strong force it can actually lift up the
weight of that string do it again learn
okay
this way this time and then of course
somebody asked me to blow a bubble so
again regular bubbles and regular
bubbles have this nice shape of being a
sphere because the sphere is if we
enclose some area is the shape that
minimizes the amount of surface area so
it solves a mathematical problem of
minimizing surface area because of that
force the bubbles wants to pull together
and minimize the amount of surface that
has those you know that has those
unhappy molecules with less baggage I'm
going to show you one or two more
technology so some of you have seen some
of these outside but when you make a
soap bubble between two plates that are
clear like Plexiglas that have pins in
them the so-called the likes to connect
those pins and it will do so in a way
that will minimize the distance
minimizes the distance between two
points and we all know that the answer
to that is a straight line so that's a
very simple mathematical problem but we
can see what happens if we want to
connect
points
and that's the shape of a soap bubble
that is sure this distance
connecting three points and so that of
course is a lie because here we are
Yale and so so these are interesting but
kind of give you an advertisement for
coming back outside afterwards and show
you some more complicated kinds of
problems you can solve obviously I can
put as many pins in as many different
geometries as I like place so I'll show
you some that you can see outside and
then I'll just finish with one last
demonstration that's more
three-dimensional cities in the United
States and we can ask the question of
what's the best way to connect all these
cities with optical fiber for running
all your computers and the soap bubbles
will solve that pretty in about the same
time as some computers and then we can
also ask what if we have many pins that
are great and sort of a great giveaway
that we call like a crystal lattice and
this will solve some other problems in
physics and mathematics then I'm gonna
actually do the one with four pins which
looks simple but
I don't know anybody gasps the best way
to connect up for tens but it's not
maybe what you originally thought the
interesting thing about this solution is
that the original problem with four pins
has things that we call symmetries you
can rotate by 90 degrees or you can flip
over and those pins have the exact same
pattern but the solution does not
respect those symmetries if I rotate the
solution by 90 degrees it actually is
different from the Lumbees there looks
like that however I'm just going to
finish now with a more three-dimensional
demonstration smooth the kids already
sold this outside we can take a cube
here and tip it
I'll dip another one a little bit larger
holding this one up
and if I'm careful I'll just drive one
more thing for fun I will dip this again
and now I can produce a bubble where I
have a inside
okay so that's so the nation over good
sentence for how molecules on the
surface sir not as happy as molecules
inside of the material and how that can
make some pretty cool shapes and that's
actually the force that makes that drop
the water round up so you have a really
small drop of water that surface tension
force is strong enough to beat gravity
and so it rounds up but if you have a
big drop of water there's just not as
many enough things on the surface to be
grabbing so it stays nice okay but
surface tension is not important just
for liquids and a lot of people have
heard of surface tension in the context
of bubbles before it's also really
importantly in terms of solid materials
- and this is what ties in to the
research that I'm doing in my own
laboratory and first I want to motivate
its with certain little thought
experiment here and that here we have a
one material term against nothing it's
like air on one side but now imagine if
I put two different types of materials
next to each other okay there's a
greeting material on top of the blue
material the green material up on the
top can connect with all its other green
friends okay so it's very very happy
the who walketh material can connect
with lots of friends of the same color
the ones that are on the surface of the
globe which are gray can make
connections with the green
student they might be stronger actually
they might like to be with the green
more than they want to be to blue or the
Bible to be looking for their read
themselves more my point here is that
even when you have two materials next to
each other there is a surface tension
between two different materials and this
is actually how sticky notes work okay
so in the sticky note you have the back
of the backside of the sticky note is
this sticky material right that sticky
material has a surface tension okay and
it turns out that that material is
really happy when you put it against
another solid surface okay
so you can make it can make bonds with
the other material they're not as strong
as the bonds that it makes with itself
but it's enough to make that sticky note
stick to the wall basically how to make
better sticky notes right I mean make
sticky notes that are stronger or sticky
notes that can be used in biomedical
application not sticky notes but imagine
you know it isn't fun taking off a
better game really it depends on if
you're the person who's wearing the
bandage or the person taking off the
bandage
okay anyway it might be this a person
that's especially not fun when you're
taking it off yourself right so what if
we have like 50 it's that like digging
verb but you could take them up wouldn't
that be awesome
yeah understand how these things work
and one of the key things that happens
is what happens microscopically of with
how the sticky note touches the surface
and I'm going to show you a really cool
movie that dr. Kate for my baby which
she couldn't come today but this is a
really nice suit
so this this is um this little sphere is
really tiny
okay take one of your hairs and imagine
that your hair some of us imagine a
little ball that's tender and smaller
than the width of your hair so it's a
really really really small ball okay and
she brings this little ball and we're
looking at with the microscope and we're
bringing in the back of the sticky note
okay and we're asking well what does
that look like we won't understand
exactly how these business the surface
sticks through the back
okay so I'm going to play the movie so
now she's pushing her sphere
okay it made that sense that was me um
so what does this what does this look
like to you yeah solid material to you
yes you've got the clean right the
people who've said kind of all right so
someone shout out why do they think this
looks like a solid material just shove
it out yeah yeah so it turns out that
the way you know that on with sticky
notes the the material has aspects of
both the liquid and the solid if we're
trying to understand how all that stuff
works this is what ladies on the
material can both be like literally
whoever solid and now we have a whole
bunch of other examples that we're going
to give you about how materials can act
like the loop of your song so I want to
start off by talking about the solids
burn so I'm just going to
my rubber ball wow that's really weird
into it cracked into two pieces
okay but life isn't active like the
liquid blue shirt yeah
yeah yeah
exactly so when I balanced it it really
looks like a solid right and there
should be another movie this is a movie
I made last night I drove my wife crazy
but here it is this is this is this is
what this is like a sped up version of
that ball Melton okay so if it's hard if
you stare at this ball you can't really
see it changing a chain but if you take
a picture every 10 seconds or 20 seconds
or a minute for an hour and a half you
can capture the whole process of this
ball sort of losing right so here going
when I when I slow down if when I take a
slow movie and I speed it up really fast
it looks like a liquid but if I do
things quickly and acts like the stall
so if you do things fast it acts like a
solid if you do things yeah so that's
the big so yeah so that's the big
question what is the stuff made up
why is act like a liquid but is so darn
slow anybody have ideas in the back
yeah so okay so they hears that the
temperatures actually not change it so
right now it's at room temperature right
and it bounces and if I hear one more
time it's going to stay at room
temperature and it's gonna sag again so
this is a very different type it's an
excellent hypothesis but this is a very
type of solid to liquid transition it
doesn't happen with temperature
it happens with the timing in fact it's
really just a flick with the whole time
it just goes really really slowly any
other hypotheses about why this thing
alright keep with straws it's thick yeah
okay it's heavy heavy so let's talk
about thick if you're gonna make
something that's thick what do you want
to do how do you make it thick push it
again yeah okay so why don't I show you
what a picture what this thing looks
like zoom in okay so now we're zooming
really really deep like so this scalebar
is a nanometer okay so it turns out that
like water molecules which are basically
little spheres that sort of look like a
Mickey Mouse but basic little spheres
these molecules in this material are
really long
they're like yarn okay if you have lots
of pieces
long yarn and you dumped them into a
container what happens to them yeah
right there they settle in because of
gravity what else and you want to get
one of them out what happens yeah
they get tangled okay so in this
material this isn't you love me had a
really long stringy molecules called
polymers okay and powder is just word
for really long straight material and
they're so long that they get all
tangled up
okay so gravity's pulling this down but
because they're tangled it takes a
really really long okay let's make sense
okay so this is solid if you do things
quickly and liquid if you go slowly and
the difference between solid and liquid
is about a catalyst it takes it really
an hour for it to act like like a we're
going to show you another material now
that has a difference between being a
solid and a liquid on a lot shorter
timescale so let me see if we can figure
out what bucking press
all right so we're going to be 120 demo
is this little water okay great so this
is starting to get a PhD in chemical
engineering okay great okay and the
inside of the speaker he has blue water
what's this thing that it's holding
that's rings what do you do with this
range yeah you can you can inject stuff
before you inject you have to suck now
so can you show everybody just how you
suck up water with a syringe so he
sticks the water into he sticks the
syringe into the water and he pulls up
and if he pulls the syringe out of the
water and keeps and he keeps pulling
does he keep them you are watering
what is it yet right do it one more time
great
yeah okay so now we're gonna take any
material that looks like this okay this
is what we call a polymer solution okay
so it's got those same love molecules
that gets him build up but there's not
as many of them so they don't get
tangled up with each other
they just get tangled up with themselves
so it makes me act like a solid only if
you do things really put okay they're
like in less than a second it's gonna
act at the Salah but more than a second
is going to act like a liquid so let's
see what happens when younggu tries to
pull that into this room
so he's still pulling when he pulls the
syringe out of the liquid it keeps
getting pulled up so if you can't see it
right here you can see it on the screen
let's do it again for everybody so it's
sort of like in this case pulling why is
the staff acted like a solid when you
use the syringe yeah you want to sell I
said acting like a song that's what it's
you do is sort of solid exactly also if
this was a piece of yarn yes if you got
to straighten made out of a solid and
you pulled the string made out of solid
it'd be no problem pulling it up at all
right trying to pull out uh string out
of like leave it just doesn't work
so this thing that he's playing with is
like 90% water and only 10% of this but
he can still just pull it up because
it's just barely a liquid and if he does
it too slowly it will just
materials okay this up see is starting
to jerk a little bit my rubber balls are
looking so every day both are fats when
you go ashore over short times in there
sorry stalling for short times we put on
one of them but they have different
times for the transfer now I'm going to
tell you about another material we're
going to talk about cornstarch which is
also known as blue-black I'll be
introduce my colleague professor Evans
from the Department of Mechanical
Engineering you can call dr. swishing
today legacy be playing out by the
cornstarch cool outside so I'm going to
tell you a lot more not cornstarch this
is just a very fun material to play with
also has solid good properties so my
coming here dr. by I she's going to show
you what happens when you mix cornstarch
and water
so he's mixed some cornstarch and water
together at this bowl and you can see
it's kind of wobbling around there it's
sloshing around like a like fluid right
to me kind of like milk or something
right right and what if he stirs it
slowly so it still looks like a liquid
right yeah okay what if he stirs it
faster
any faster
so actually if he hits it it's it's kind
of hard right doctor by a hard material
right it almost feels like a solid if
you put this up and you guys you don't
have to take our word for it you can go
up and play with it up later yeah so it
feels really hard so here you can see
the crack so people because these green
color is hot you see that yeah material
crack
you guys remember college yeah so so it
has properties of both liquids and
solids right yeah so if they're floating
like the liquid but it's Harmon and
crack like a solid yeah this one's me
more
you know we'll pick it up like a solid
bit and it melts it houses hand
so again it's it's very solid like that
it can melt like a lip day so so you
guys can play with this stuff at home
you can buy corn starch at grocery store
put in a bowl just add some water about
50 percent water 50 percent corn starch
you guys can play with this home you can
do all parts you can stir it you can't
eat it you can find like make a ball out
of it and throw it around make a big
mess in your kitchen that's great so I
want to show you start some water on a
speaker this is like a stereo speaker
and we're going to shake that speaker
and so so again it looks like a liquid
ever
yes that looks like a movement for me
what up you see it
yeah
yeah we're supposed to make like like we
got late right giving the class service
I don't know what happened so somewhere
scientists and engineers so we do a lot
of experience
so it was only a solid but we move it
fast just like a lot like a silly funny
although this is a different material
slow moving fast as a solid I'm going to
show you again you might have seen this
outside and if you haven't seen this you
should see it outside you can see you
can actually run across the surface so
you see there that's not sinking into
the into the water start to water right
so you can see waves that looks to me
like the fluid I started to drop a
pebble into a lake right it made waves
like that but but the first pot sinking
in right there walking on it like it was
a solid
so this is a cool thing you can do with
the material EPA it look like a fluid
and like a solvent but you have to put
pretty fast so this is different than
the silly putty you saw before that's
the only funny is still melting now that
more start so we got to move fast
Thank You Brendan like this to stay up
if I stop running in that I'm gonna sink
right in so so you have to keep moving
fast to keep that like this office but
if you think in please
you might sink to the bottom and you
might have a hard time getting out you
have to try it out by experiment
I want to try to explain a little bit
about what's going on here at least what
we understand about this so if I if I
would bookmarks our article under a
microscope I get a picture that looks
like that so these are actual corn
starch article if they look like tiny
boxes the scale here this is one ten
thousandth of a meter this is a little
smaller than the thickness of your air
is too small to see the particles by so
they're really tiny there's a bunch of
little tiny box and I've put a little
bit like at the top right picture there
they kind of float around and like you
saw it look like milk it looks still
like look with those particles floating
around but what happened when we when we
moved it back so we started fast or we
shook it or or someone stepped on it
what happened did you push those
particles together and if you push them
together fast enough you can kind of jam
together like a solid to you as well
push together at bottom take your hand
and then if they're all stuck together
like that Nick and act like the solid is
there hard particles so then you can
have a cantar
they can even cracked like a solid it
can hold up so much weight if they try
to run across it fast enough but you
have to just push it from together to do
that if you let go if you stop stirring
or stop pushing and those particles
float away
again you're going to have that picture
again so you have to keep pushing them
fast to get them to stay like a Salomon
so this is that what we understand about
how these materials
and great and then is going to do
another experiment course and this is
this is a cool application of his
material cornstarch more so so so again
if you do a lot of experience with these
things that we try to figure out what
are these materials for food with 9001
day and actually I can't take credit for
there's other people out of this thing
yeah but but these poor start to more
mature lazy good for protecting things
what happens if you drop an egg water
happen
yeah so so the water did not protect
that egg at all right so salar is it not
good like if you wanted to make a helmet
person so addict you would not make that
water right you'd be a scrambled egg a
sport so now the cornstarch what's going
to happen
sometimes we have to try experiments
more than once
what is it how high do you think we
could toss it and and yet we still
survived
do you guys think
yeah
so I wouldn't I would accept it too much
I once want to fall from the ceiling and
have that protect me but it could
protect you a little bit right so so
this is one of the things we do we try
to study this stuff to try to understand
if we drop that egg on the solid ground
you know you think about that picture on
the left there if you give that egg it's
going to hit the ground and all the
force of that impact is something
concentrated at a point at the end of
that egg where that Red Square is hey so
protecting something it does it's not
just the amount of force that matters
but the concentration of that person so
if you were to cook that egg with
something sharp though when we put it in
the bag with cornstarch the material
starts out as a fluid so that who is
surrounded the egg pretty evenly and it
only turns into a solid when the egg
impacts so it has a chance for the fluid
to form around the material and give a
lot of coverage so you see that red line
there that's representing how much of
the surface area of the egg is contacted
by the fluid by the time it turns into a
solid with the force from the attacker
spread out over that larger area so it's
not as concentrated of force on the egg
and the egg is safer to command and that
that would be work the same way
protective material based on the double
pad or helmet or something protective
element it does that by spreading out
the force so so I'll tell you there are
there are some things that we we don't
understand about the market are together
and that's why we study it as scientists
and engineers so so we still try to
understand things like how fast you have
to stir this triangle solid so you don't
really have new prediction for health
for how that is understandable things we
don't understand others and if you
really want to design materials with
specific applications like protective
gear we want to be able to predict these
things and understand how changing the
material properties or changing those
particles would give us different effect
materials
and the Berto and let me summarize for
the key points to remember okay so first
thing we talked about is that service
veteran squeezes on with the con
materials to make the surface smaller
and that's why snowdrops roundup and
fluids take while foods can change their
shape when they're push solids like to
keep their own shape when they're closed
and then probably a bigger or more
important lesson that's important for
all the physics and chemistry not just
for the squishy stuff is that big things
and small things behave differently okay
and then that's the important general
point is that some materials act like
solids or for short times and liquids
over a long time okay so those are the
things to remember I'm going to be
sticking around the recipe was going to
be sticking around and answer any
questions you might have
I would also like to point out the quest
our school is going to be here for a
while so if you haven't had a chance we
have SEF and your parents answer okay
they can go get messy and it's lots of
fun and
by saying that all the people are today
by real people okay then you'll get a
chance to meet some of us today